donc vous avez pris des missions à long terme chez
Locke et MacArthur la frange c'est
ce que les travaux j'ai une règle juste une
si vous ne voulez pas être ici ne venez pas
ce que vous voulez que j'aille au
bureau du doyen sur  votre chemin où vous l'avez
trouvé oppa pouvez-vous me prêter dix dollars
allez mec j'ai faim pourquoi me traites-
tu comme un gamin eh bien tu es un gamin
je te regarde à l'école tu as toujours l'
air si triste tu vis le tordu
Tommy de
retour le  merde [ __ ] de [ __ ] de singe
merdique ffffff ouais j'étais très en
colère aussi ouais je choisis un état sans
raison d'être en colère contre moi parce que je suis l'
une des rares personnes ici essayant
de te donner une opportunité qu'un autre
étudiant a sauvé
j'aime  l'enseignement voyez-vous les gars êtes les
vrais héros
où sont tous les parents eh bien
comme la seule famille que j'ai jamais eue
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi je ne peux pas être votre famille
vous
[Musique]